[Music]
it's production of crops a very easy
practice can I just buy a piece of land
and begin farming can a small land give
me the yield of a big one let me give
you an example we have two men who are
farmers the first one named Samir has
two hectares of flat while the other
whose name is ronan has four hectares of
land the former one invests in a tractor
fertilisers and many other types of
equipment the latter has land but cannot
afford to buy any of these equipments
what would be the resulting yield Samir
had a higher quantity of crop produced
even in a small piece of land Ronon did
not have the finances to help him make a
profitable harvest this example tells us
that the inputs in farming are directly
related to the yield of the land does
higher the cost of production better the
yield when a farmer has an ability to
purchase high-end technological
equipments his cropping system varies
and he can earn more from his land based
on this monetary aspect of farming there
are three different types of production
in farming a production based on no cost
at all this is when a farmer does not
invest in any equipments of farming
paraphernalia to better his production
second would be the low cost production
and third is the high cost production so
what are the things that characterized
this kind of production on which level
does the farmer need to invest in to
enhance his yield three main components
need to be taken into consideration
while talking about crop production
management firstly let us look at
nutrient management secondly we must
look at irrigation of the farms yes
water is a very important requirement
for a farmer and thirdly we must look at
the cropping patterns let us look at the
first one in this video what do we mean
by nutrient management how can we manage
the nutrient intake of plants we
require food for a growth and survival
we also choose food items we need the
most and eat those nutrients which our
body lacks similarly plants do need a
variety of nutrients they generally need
about 16 nutrients in all from where do
you think they get these nutrients
plants are in contact with the air water
and soil it must be these very places
which provide them with nutrients if
that is so what nutrients do you think
air will provide plants with we have
studied in lower grades that plants
require both oxygen and carbon dioxide
these nutrients are provided to the
plants by air what about water
take a guess let me give you a hint
these are the components that make the
water molecule hydrogen oxygen yes h2o
tells us that water provides plants with
hydrogen and oxygen let us look at soil
soil provides plants with many nutrients
some of them are required in large
quantities by plants while some are
required in smaller quantities the ones
which are required in larger quantities
are called as macronutrients while the
smaller quantity ones are called as
micronutrients nitrogen phosphorus
potassium calcium magnesium and sulfur
are the macronutrients while iron
manganese boron zinc copper molybdenum
and chlorine are micronutrients so how
can we enhance crop production we must
first see to it that the plants get all
these nutrients if nutrients are
deficient then the plant is susceptible
to many diseases and it can affect
growth as well as the reproduction
nutrient management is an important
aspect of crop production management but
how can we add nutrients to the soil we
will look at that in our next video
[Music]